dear delegates to the women 20 summit
thank you for your invitation and for
your work
which is now more important than ever
at the next g20 summit in rome i could
be
the only woman in the group
and there could be no better reminder of
how long
the road towards gender equality still
is
and this is the very reason why we need
your expertise
we need women 20 to help bring the voice
of
women at the table of decision makers
we need the best policy ideas so that
more and more women
all around the world can get the right
opportunities
and eventually reach the leadership
positions
that they deserve
there are three policies that i would
like to mention today
first on education
you all know that the pandemic is
leading to the worst education crisis in
modern history
around 11 million girls might be forced
out of school this would be a massive
setback
on the path towards equality so the
question is
can we avoid this and how
last month at the g7 i announced that
the european commission
will increase by one-third our
contribution to the global partnership
for education we will reach 100 million
euros per year
guaranteed for seven years in a row
to help achieve the goal of 40 million
more girls in schools by 2026
and i would like the g20 summit to also
make a clear commitment to education
for all girls in the world
second on women employment
too many of us have been told that we
had to choose
between being a mother and having a
career
as a mother of seven and as president of
the european commission
i beg to differ
i know the obstacles that women face so
we must strive
to create the right conditions for all
women
to enjoy equal access to the job markets
and to raise their children in the
european union
we have just agreed to cut the gender
employment gap
by 50 by 2030
and i will bring this commitment to the
leaders table at the g20 in october
but to achieve this goal women need
the right support we need
parental payments and parental leave
for mothers and fathers we need to offer
more and better child care and we must
strengthen elderly
care these policies require a cultural
shift
but also adequate resources
in europe we are financing some of these
reforms
through our recovery plan we call it
next generation eu
and our new budget now it is time to
bring this conversation to the g20
and this is my third point let us talk
about
how to finance child care parental
leaves
parental payments education and training
because this is the investment we need
for solid and sustainable recovery so i
look forward to seeing
your recommendations ahead of the g20
summit
with your help we can put equality
between women and men at the core of the
g20 agenda
so that women and men are equally
represented
in the workforce in family life
and yes in g20 meetings too
thank you very much and let me wish you
all the best
for these three days of work